hello everyone and welcome back to the
first game that finished uh from the
round three of the tata still chess
tournament 2022 it's young sister of
duda versus magnus carlsen and as you
guys already know duda qualifies for the
next candidates tournament so if he wins
that he might be challenging magnus for
the title if magnus ever agrees to play
for the title again uh as he did say
that he will only play alireza for the
title but uh we will see when it finally
happens
will that be the case
so uh duda has the white pieces and he
opens with e4 that we have e5 knight to
f3 knight to c6 we have bishop to b5
going for the royal opus and now a6
morphy's defense and uh as you guys know
magnus announced that he is going for
that 2900 uh classical rating which is
incredibly difficult to achieve and he
will have to you know continually just
beat opponent after opponent and a very
very high rated opponent because so far
he drew one game and won one game and he
won like uh a point and a half so yeah
it's not gonna it's not gonna be easy so
here a six morphe defense with bishop to
a4 knight to f6 uh and now we have
castles we have bishop to e7 and now
rook to e1 so here b5 attacking the
bishop bishop to b3 and castles and this
is the position that we had in many
games uh during carlson's world church
championship match with janni pognashi
where everyone was asking the question
where we'll see the uh c3 and the d5 the
marshall attack on the board uh that is
uh well what we all want to see but
unfortunately we didn't see it and we
will not be seeing it this game so here
uh usually nowadays players don't go for
c3 they go for some sort of an
anti-martial line with either h3 or a4
and in this game uh we have a4 so going
after that b5 pawn that we have rook to
b8 and now a capture on b5 with eight
captures and now h3 uh we have d6 just
continuing development uh and this is uh
pretty much following the game uh
exactly uh
uh from the carlson nipple world chess
championship match where if you guys
remember in game five uh or rather in
game seven d3 was played uh but uh here
we have c3 it's a continuation um uh
nipple played against magnus in game
five of the world chess championship
match and we have b4 magnus continues in
the same fashion as he did against
nipple d3 with b captures on d3 b
captures on c3 and now in the actual
game magnus versus nepo d5 was played by
magnus but here uh magnus plays h6 and
the h6 is not a new move uh
interestingly uh duda already had this
exact same position and he played h6 so
magnus here kind of plays the
duda's move against him
but only in that game knight beta d2 was
played but here uh we have
after h6 with bishop to e3 and this is
now a new move so already as of move 14
we have a completely new game
magnus continues with rook to e8 he has
h6 rook d8 and now he's going to bring
the bishop over to f8 so if at some
point you want to play d5 you will be
able to and the rook will nicely control
the e file so here knight b to d2 and
bishop to f8 and both players uh spent
pretty much zero time there these were
all uh instant moves uh and that this is
the first time that duda starts thinking
and he spent 30 minutes on his next move
deciding on whether to go for some
problem well maybe some bishop to c4
maybe some g4 advancements or just queen
to c2 nicely developing the queen
and the connecting the rook so here like
i said a 30 minute thing and the magnus
pretty much instantly replied with
bishop to e6 now offering a trade of
bishops plus you're putting a lot of
pressure on this b3 bishop so you have
to be careful not to move the d to
knight
and there are a couple of uh ideas here
that you could make for example you
could play bishop to a4 just attack the
the knight here and uh bishop d7 we
might even see a repetition if this was
played that should be three bishop e6
bishop a4 bishop to d7 uh very likely we
wouldn't but it is possible another
thing after bishop to e6 you could play
rook to a6 first prepare bishop to a6
then it's going to be a double attack on
the knight but then we just see a trade
for example captures captures queen d7
connecting the rooks and the defending
the knight on c6
uh however instead after bishop to e6 uh
duda just trades with bishop captures
root captures and now strikes in the
center with d4 so duda is already down
to 48 minutes on the clock and this is
the first time magnus started thinking
in the game
and after some time he went e captures
on d4
now uh how do you continue here well you
could capture with the pawn or you could
capture with the knight capturing with
the pawn isn't all that impressive
because there's this annoying knight to
be for move attacking the
the queen on c2 and after the queen
moves because you have to keep an eye on
the e4 pawn so you have to keep the
queen on this diagonal but also that's
very annoying because the rook is on b8
but okay if you move the knight and we
move the queen it's it's not a problem
uh queen e8 we add the third attacker to
the e4 pawn now we push e5 for example
captures captures now knight fd5 so this
is something that could happen but this
is uh
black would very much enjoy uh playing
this position so instead after this e
captures on d4 duda plays knight
captures on d4 we have knight captures
and b for c characters and now queen to
e8 now magnus goes after the e4 pawn and
duda plays d5 now uh chases away the
rook but also just uh well prepares the
rook to a4
then the uh the e4 pawn will be nicely
defended so here we have rook back to e7
and now rook to a4 duda defends the pawn
here and this is the only good way to
defend the pawn for example if you move
the bishop yes the rook now defends the
pawn but then you run into something
like this and the rokuni one uh well uh
you you cannot play this so instead
after rook to e7 we have rook to a4
and now we have rook to b2 going for
that uh
uh very very aggressive line uh with
rook to b2 rook the c8 is another way
you could play this just adding another
defender here and trying to force c5 but
i guess magnus was trying to wait with
this for example c1 uh we're going to
push c5d captures on c6 but this is now
very well protected and if you bring
more defenders we're going to bring if
you bring more attackers we're going to
bring more defenders and now you have
this funky position where some ideas
like knight to d7 are possible with the
idea of shifting the knight to e5 going
after the pawn here and now we might
even see a you know just an all-out
trade here just c captures through
captures d captures an ea bringing a
queen into the game rook captures and c1
would check knight f1
rook captures on f1 with cha king f1 and
rook captures on e8 and we would have
this position where it's pretty much a
a completely equal end game
uh that's why instead after rook day
four rook the b2 was played uh trying to
get the queen away from the defense of
the uh rook and a4 this is how magnus
will uh further activate the queen and
the queen from a4 will also put pressure
on e4 so that works out very well so
here queen captures we have queen
captures on a4 and now bishop to d4
putting pressure on the knight so what
do you play here magnus plays knight to
h5 the knight is now coming to f4 and
rook to a1 chasing away carlson's queen
we have queen back to d7 and now queen
to c3 so dude again wants to play rook
to c1 and put pressure on that c7 pawn
and the magnus wants to play c5 at some
point to create a pass pawn it's either
going to be a past c pawn or if d
captures c6 up a son then it's going to
be a past d-pawn so here we have knight
to f4 by magnus and now uh well you have
to be careful if you play rook to c1
then 92 with this beautiful fork so you
don't want this to happen so instead
queen f3 attacking the knight guarding
the e2 square knight back to g6 here
magnus did uh think about the position a
little bit because obviously we have to
consider g5 uh it looks uh like it might
be played if the knight can remain on f4
but we're just gonna kick it away with
the g3 h4 and you well uh you've
unnecessarily weakened your king's
position so instead after queen f3
knight back to g6 and now only now rook
to c1
we have queen to a4 going after the
bishop here the situation on the clock
is 28 minutes for duda and some 36
minutes for magnus
we have queen d3 defending the bishop
here and now what do you play well now
the thing is if magnus goes c5 right now
then d captures on c6 and after rook to
c7 going after the pawn we're going to
play queen c4 defend and offer a queen
trade let's say captures captures and
now just knight goes after the pawn here
for example knight to f1 we're gonna
trade here rook captures rook captures
knight captures and it's uh well equal
material pretty much an an equal end
game uh so that's why after this queen
to d3 move magnus plays f5 he wants to
weaken a white center and then at some
point when the situation is just right
executed the c5 move or maybe c6
depending on what will suit the position
better so here we have g3 duda wants
magnus to capture on e4 so he can play
knight captures on e4 and
improve the position of his knight and
also this nicely controls the the knight
and g6 uh if you play f4 here g4 is very
nice so dude i'm not worried about this
so magnus just captures an e4 knight
captures an e4 and now queen back to e8
putting pressure on this knight here so
knight back to c3 and now magnus goes
for rook to e1 with check rook captures
we have queen captures with check king
the g2 and now crossings knight on g6 is
hanging so he needs to bring the queen
back queen to e8 uh and the situation on
the clock is 15 minutes for duda and
some 30 minutes for magnus and here duda
has to decide whether to go for
something like h4 or or weight or just
do nothing uh he decides to go for queen
to b5 he still uh is trying to prevent
magnus from
creating just creating a pass pawn here
so queen to b5 and now magnus declines
the trade he plays queen to c8 as duda
is very low on time so it makes sense to
keep the queens on the board and now
we're gonna play c5 at some point we can
play right away because d captures on c6
just has a
protected pass pawn for white so queen
back to d3 going after the knight and
now knight to e7 we have queen to e4 and
now finally magnus creates a pass pawn
with
c6 we have d captures on c6 uh and uh
here it was in this position on move 38
that the players actually agreed to a
draw as there doesn't seem to be
anything
anything that can be achieved by other
side here point is after the pawn is
captured we can just trade here for
example captures captures attack the
bishop bishop to e3 and we will get the
exact same end game that we already
discussed only maybe the the bishop and
knight are placed a little bit
differently where magnus does have the
past deep on but still it's equal
material here aduda has three against
two and on the king's side uh it's a
very very
unlikely that you would be able to do
anything here duda is very low on time
he is below the five minute mark but
it's already they drew i think on move
36
uh let me just check um
no actually on move 38 so magnus
couldn't really hope for for anything
you know
regarding time trouble
uh so yeah uh that's uh the the update
on carlson's uh climb to the 2900 elo
mountain not going to be easy as you've
seen dude with the white pieces he just
uh you know has had no weaknesses
whatsoever for the entire game
so magnus will have to look for his
chances with the white pieces but still
if he can get draws with black wins with
white uh could be
uh could be that this will be a very
successful event as uh i imagine he will
not be happy with the event even if he
wins it if he if he loses rating
so yeah uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it it's the absolute first game
that finished all the other games are
still going on so i decided to you know
make a video to briefly inform you on
what happened and if you guys have a
some of your own favorites do you
suggest them we're going to cover them
as well so far i believe the the the the
favorite but it's still going on is um
double versus vedic so we'll see what
happens in that one uh so yeah once
again hope you guys enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank joseph henderson uh
frank home sian topless uh richard
thoman and robert youngquist for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing the coverage of
this wonderful event until it finishes
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day